I was gonna breasts my name is Claire
what um what's it is here let's play so
welcome to dodge sick ball gyro yeah
okay cashton
cashton mean forward it for three I'm
late I have no idea you play this game
sure you probably just nerd it out yes
rude rude let me go ah Brennan will
destroy you stop get away from me get
away get away
missed me so violent I like it
ah stop hitting how do you do that ah ah
urine got hit in the butt what a dick
how what you gonna do what you gonna do
what you get look I dodge these like neo
dodges bullets
hide behind the visto that's what mom
always said you should wish wish to do
you have a Vista in your hand like over
the Vistula Marzia oh my god hey hey hey
hey hey hey be careful with that
versatile hey no no you
aah how dare you slap when we never stow
all right you know what I'm gonna slap
you with a Vishal I haven't thought
about that okay you want some damn it I
missed give me another one another I
don't hit me with a sausage
come on oh my god you broke the whole
machine he's gonna go on and employ now
what's it worth that you made me soil
myself why am I losing suck on this and
suck on this oh my god I killed you
sure you
yeah that's right hahahahaha ah no hot
dog give me a hot dog here ah right in
the bud I can't feel my legs
no you want
oh my god no hey Martha hit me hit me my
sin that's right okay we got a shield I
got it
what Hey then I'm just pissed myself hey
I got bees go my minions you want some
of this oh that's good yeah you did hey
bees you want some beers Brad okay No ah
damn I gotta hate Carson get a job
Karsten Oh God okay you blocked me out
don't touch me and I'm the winner again
you have an alcohol problem
hey dr. crabby sure ah shitty got my
nipple Oh
tsunami jellyfish
yeah you want a jelly up cuz your jelly
nipples give me power ya know you don't
oh god I got so many crabs please good
no come on yeah but this is like epic
anime fight from epic addict yeah Sasuke
are you not dead yet hey ma yet headshot
that's right hey can I get an ice cream
please a magnum hey what
why don't we let's piss myself I'm not
worried
okay I'm worried are you
boom oh my god Jesus Christ no no no no
I'm about to and everything in my all
right burn yeah go burn destroy I'm
gonna eat you match point for pants yeah
you can't hit this oh yeah god say
something I'm giving up on you yeah it's
too too don't worry about it hey no no
no no no no are you kidding me hey can I
drop the joystick I'll drop the joist
I'll drop you have you thought about
that you promised you would let me win
for
all right thank you so much for watching
much thank you for joining and I'm such
a good boy friends we're letting you win
and live like we enjoyed and it'll see
you in the next one it's always come on
just come on right damn now let's rock
oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dammit